last 48 hours you've gotten into a
little bit of a back and forth with the
governor of New York it should be
pointed out started by the governor of
New York who invoked you in talking
about his own problems in Albany what is
driving the back and forth on Twitter
between you and the governor you know
but you're not doing I'm in the media
now and I write for the Daily News as
you know journalist is this designer
you've always been in the media they
always been and you spend more time on
television anchors in I've actually been
kind of a kind of Tommy let's face the
governor cuomo's had a tough time he
basically ran a non-primary primary
where he duck you duck someone he
should've been Duffy should've been
debating ran an issue list campaign and
I wrote about that he's been he's been
for some reason he's getting roughed up
in the media as he should for pummeling
the mayor of our city who's just trying
to govern the city in the mayor and the
governor every chance he said steps on
it he closes our subway when someone
sneezes hard he had it coming a little
bit but you know and so I to be honest
with you the most interesting thing
about the Twitter back and forth is his
is he apparently has a professional
spokesman which I which is mind-boggling
to me is actually getting help with this
stuff but all of that being said I've
been I've been I've been cuz somewhat
critical of him but i have to tell you
there are some things she's done that I
like a lot I like his idea of having
finally having a train go into laguardia
for example but but if it's do you think
why do you think they came back at you I
think they may want to perhaps change
the conversation I mean they in so many
I mean there must be spending a lot of
time you know ducting subpoenas and
stuff that it might be the kind of thing
that seemed like right there what what
there you are you did do that look I'm
just trying to keep me and I saw that
don't think they went between you and
see what she was there oh you invoked in
one of your tweets the notion that
there's accusations out there in some
sense that perhaps they interfere with
with investigation do you think the
governor right now is in some peril with
the US Attorney's well actually
interesting and in my weekly appearance
on New York one time warner cable yeah
all right wise guy I actually I actually
think that pre has gone way overboard
and saying things to the governor like
you know don't put out talking points
about my case because it's witness
tampering it was a joke that's what we
do we joke it you know as Oscar said to
Felix once it's too hot stay out of
Hell's Kitchen where you know we're just
having a little fun house Carl someone
said Felix Felix Felix I could kill you
much is it much as it pains me because
I'd like to have this conversation all
day because we get this we can stir up
another regular be alike the way to the
counter I'm because I'm in the media now
you keep this we keep this feud going
all day